[musique]
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Estelle Yussoufa, je suis député de la
première circonscription de Mayotte.
Commission des affaires étrangères.
Ah, je suis membre de la commission des
affaires étrangères, la Commission des
affaires européennes, vice-présidente de
la délégation Outre à l'Assemblée
nationale.
Donc, on vous a demandé de venir pour
parler Mayotte, immigration, commission
des affaires étrangères, stratégie
stratégie de l'immigration, pas
d'immigration.
Je vais vous poser une question toute
bête. Comment ça va Mayotte en ce moment
?
C'est tendu,
c'est euh on est sur un fil, c'est
compliqué, on a repris espoir.
Pourquoi ? parce que le gouvernement a
fait un virage à 180° avec l'opération
Bouchou, ce qui nous donne l'espoir de
nous dire que l'État a pris conscience
de la crise à Mayotte après des années
d'inertie et de laisser faire, après une
politique qui a été soit d'ignorer le
problème de l'immigration clandestine,
soit de l'accueillir.
Et là en fait avec l'opération embouchou
qui est menée à la demande de nous les
élus de Mayotte et de la population, le
ministre d'Armanin a mobilisé des forces
de l'ordre, les forces
de centaines de fonctionnaires pour
mettre en place cette opération qui a
été très longue à démarrer et cetera.
Mais le signal politique, il est
important parce que en fait boufou ça
les élections, c'est ça ? Non, c'est pas
une question électorale. Les scores de
du président Macron à Mayotte sont
catastrophiques. Euh enfin, je veux
dire, c'est pas euh c'est pas du
clientélisme politique bien qu'il y ait
toujours des responsés évidemment, mais
c'est pas ça. C'est la gravité de la
situation qui fait que pour les
autorités, euh ça devient impossible à
ignorer et que après des années d'échec
d'une politique qui nous a amené dans le
mur, bah là soit on prend Mayotte par la
peau du dos et on nous sort du
précipice, soit on lâche. Et donc
Wamboufou,
je sais pas si vous lâchez
Wamboufou, ça a permis quand même de
soulever le couvercle de la marmite he
parce que ça a été bat les masques. Les
autorités comorienne ont montré leur
vrai visage que beaucoup à Paris
voulaient ignorer en continuant leur
revendication sur Mayotte. Ça a mis à
bas tout le discours sur la coopération
France Comor qui serait utile, qui
permettrait de sortir
et d'avancer. Ben en fait non. En fait,
on voit bien que ça ne permet pas
d'avancer, que c'est complètement
inutile et que c'est juste à nos frais.
Et puis ça permet aussi de de montrer
que la question migratoire n'est pas
qu'une question de misère humaine à
Mayotte. C'est un trafic humain, c'est
une violence inouie, c'est une économie
clandestine, c'est une situation qui
n'est pas tenable dans un état de droit.
Donc euh c'est pour ça que pour nous, on
reprend espoir parce qu'on se dit euh
d'abord il y a une solidarité nationale
qui s'exprime. 75 % des Français
soutiennent l'opération en bouchou. Euh
ça nous a donné beaucoup de visibilité
pour Mayotte. C'est important parce
qu'on est une île où on se sent
invisible.
La source des 75 % c'est quoi ? C'est un
sondage à ris pour LCI
euh qui a été fait euh il y a une
quinzaine de jours et euh c'est
important pour nous parce que on sort de
l'invisibilité,
on a une mobilisation évidemment pour
comment dire les le gouvernement c'est
totalement inespéré d'avoir une
opération officielle qui est soutenue à
75 % en cette période très compliquée
politiquement.
C'est quelque chose à laquelle le
gouvernement s'attendait pas. Mais pour
nous Maorè et Maoré, ça veut dire que on
peut va peut-être sortir de l'enfer dans
lequel on est parce qu'il y a pas
d'autres mots pour déterminer pour
expliquer ce qu'on vit au quotidien.
Alors je vous demande de déléguer le mot
enfer. Après on fera un peu d'histoire,
ensuite on va faire un peu de
prospective.
[rires]
Donc par quel vous voulez prendre ça ?
Et le bout de l'enfer. Alors
dites-moi expliquer ce qu'est l'enfer à
Mayotte.
C'est quoi l'enfer à Mayotte ? L'enfer à
Mayotte, c'est la moitié de la
population qui est étrangère en grande
partie en situation irrégulière.
C'est c'est bah je pense qu'on est à 60
70 % de la population étrangère est en
situation irrégulière à Mayotte parce
que les statistiques ne prennent pas en
compte les enfants. La moitié de la
population à Mayotte a moins de de 20
ans. Euh et donc en fait on ne prend pas
en compte les mineurs dans les
statistiques, on les compte pas, on les
compte mal. Et en fait, c'est un un
petit angle mort qui permet de masquer
la gravité de la situation à Mayotte.
C'est euh une île ou 77 % de la
population selon les statistiques qui
sont totalement fausses parce qu'en
réalité officiellement on est 300000, en
réalité on est quasiment 1 demi million.
Au bamo euh ben en fait c'est au moins
77 % de la population qui vit en dessous
du soleil de pauvreté.
Euh donc une très grande misère qui n'a
pas toujours été celle-là, contrairement
à ce qu'on peut imaginer.
Euh et euh c'est notre enfer, c'est en
fait de voir Mayotte qui était parti sur
une trajectoire de développement et qui
en fait en une dizaine douzaine d'années
a vu sa trajectoire complètement
inversée par un flux migratoire massif
qui est arrivé sur notre île et qui a
complètement saturé nos services
publics. Alors
pour que nos auditeurs comprennent bien
oui
ça veut dire quoi massif ? C'est qu'on
est passé de combien à combien
Mayotte dans les années 70 c'est 40000
personnes. Voilà, on a [rires] on a
exposé notre population en une
quarantaine d'années avec une natalité
délirante, principalement comorienne
actuellement euh avec je pense qu'il
faut il faut pour être vraiment concret,
voilà, je vais vous dire comment
non mais je vais vous expliquer ce que
ça veut dire au notre enfer pour nous
notre enfer c'est que quand vous vous
levez à Mayotte le matin, vous vous
levez très très tôt Vous vous levez vers
4h 4h 4h30 du matin. Quand vous
travaillez à 7h à moins d'une vingtaine
de kilomètres, vous vous levez et vous
allez faire ces 20 km en 2h parce qu'il
y a que quatre routes départementales
sur ces 375 km² parce qu'il y a pas eu
d'investissement de l'état. Donc déjà,
c'est hyper saturé au niveau de la
circulation. Quand vous allez vous
lever, vous allez vérifier s'il y a de
l'eau dans votre robinet parce qu'il y a
pas eu d'assez d'investissement pour
l'eau potable et donc vous avez des
coupure 3 jours par semaine à Mayotte
dans des foyers depuis 2017. C'est à peu
près ça. Et là on va au devevant d'une
grosse crise de l'eau. Donc on aura
encore moins d'eau. On va compter les
jours où on aura de l'eau. Pas ceux où
on a des coupures. Ça va être l'inverse
d'ici quelques mois seulement à Mayotte.
Et puis après vous regardez tout de
suite sur votre téléphone portable sur
Facebook les pages qui donnent l'état du
trafic et les sites où il y a des
attaques et des agressions et des
barrages et des caillassages. Ça veut
dire que la violence est telle à Mayotte
que vous faites le programme de votre
journée en fonction des émeutes et des
violences qui sont quotidiennes.
Je je le dis vraiment, c'est c'est vrai.
Quotidiennement, on vérifie où il y a eu
des attaques, où il y a eu des barrages,
où il y a eu des caillassages. Pour que
tout le monde comprenne ce qu'est un
barrage, c'est des gens qui se mettent
dans un virage, des jeunes avec des
cailloux, des barres de fer qui vont
abattre souvent un arbre et qui vont
bloquer la circulation et agresser les
les les
tous les véhicules qui passent qui qui
vont les bloquer, qui vont les
caillasser, agresser, rançonner. euh
parfois amputer les conducteurs qui ont
le malheur de tomber dans ces embuscades
et ça va amputer à la machette, ils vont
les agresser. Donc on a à Mayotte des
personnes qui ont perdu un bras, une
jambe ou alors qui ont été kidnappé lors
de ces attaques et puis euh donc on vous
détruit le véhicule, vous êtes bah vous
en fait sur le chemin de l'école ou du
travail avec votre gamin dans la
voiture, vous sortez de là complètement
traumatisé. votre famille. Donc c'est
rapporté par les gens qui passent, qui
voient, qui le mettent sur internet, sur
Facebook pour prévenir les autres
personnes qui vont prendre cette même
route sur laquelle ils sont condamnés et
vous essayez de faire tout le tour de
l'île pour éviter cette zone ou alors
vous appelez votre patron et vous dites
"Je ne peux pas venir travailler." Ça
c'est le plan barrage caillassage. Parce
que le caillassage sinon c'est quand
vous êtes dans votre maison, c'est
arrivé pour une femme qui a eu le
malheur d'habiter à côté d'un bidonville
et qui a appelé la police quand elle
était en train d'être cambriolée. Une
bande de jeunes sont venus et ont
caillassé sa maison pendant des heures.
Ça veut dire vous prenez des énormes
énormes cailloux et vous détruisez la
maison avec la personne qui est à
l'intérieur, avec sa famille. C'est
encore arrivé hier et c'était un élu qui
était dans cette maison parce que les
bandes de jeunes l'ont vu arriver dans
cette maison et ont tenté de non
seulement faire imploser toutes les
vitres, le toit et cetera, mais de de le
tuer. Voilà, c'est ça notre réalité
quotidienne à Mayotte et ça vise les
soignants, donc les bus qui transportent
nos infirmiers, nos policiers, nos nos
médecins qui sont agressés. Ça vise nos
enseignants, ça vise nos bus scolaires
avec les enfants dedans, ça vise vous et
moi qui avons le malheur de passer par
là. Donc vous vous vérifiez ça le matin,
après vous faites votre prière parce que
les gens sont très croyants et puis que
franchement faut avoir la foi pour être
un Mayotte et puis vous prenez la route
et puis là bah vous êtes en
hypertension. Donc cette hypertension
fait que à Mayotte, on a une espérance
de vie qui est de 10 ans moindre à celle
de l'hexagone. En partie parce qu'il y a
une très forte propension de maladie
liée au stress. Donc ça nous coûte en
fait celles et ceux qui échappent à ces
agressions en fait sont tués de
l'angoisse de ces agressions de
l'angoisse de savoir que ben votre frère
votre belle- sœur votre votre la
personne que vous aimez en fait est
tombée dans une embuscade et que vous
êtes au téléphone et que tout d'un coup
vous entendez une pluie de caillou sur
le véhicule parce que vous êtes en train
de discuter et que tout d'un coup on se
dit "Attends Est, je raccroche parce que
parce qu'on est tombé dans une
embuscade." Voilà, c'est arrivé à toutes
les familles à Mayotte. C'est ça notre
quotidien, c'est ça notre enfer. Et
celles et ceux qui commettent ces actes
sont souvent des mineurs euh emmenés par
leurs parents. Et opportunément, ces
agressions sont souvent dans des zones
soit qui sont l'objet de du d'une
emprise économique, c'est-à-dire que les
gangs qui se sont organisés veulent
prendre le contrôle de ces zones,
chasser les entrepreneurs Maoré, chasser
les agriculteurs Maoré pour prendre le
contrôle des terres et en fait prendre
les champs pour alimenter une
agriculture illégale et clandestine.
ou alors prendre le contrôle de
l'appareil productif, c'est-à-dire des
entreprises. C'est quoi ? C'est le z
c'està-dire que non, vous prenez pas du
tout. Ah non non non, c'est de la la
culture de la tomate de banane dans des
champs qui ont été volés. C'est-à-dire
queil y a eu toute une série
d'agressions et de meurtres
d'agriculteurs ramayotes pour permettre
au clandestin de prendre possession des
champs.
C'est ça la la violence qu'on subit à
Mayotte. C'est une violence qui s'est
insinuée dans toute notre société.
Il y a jamais de repost de la
population. Il y a eu des tentatives de
repost, mais il y a surtout il y a
surtout eu il y a surtout eu pour nous
euh la certitude que notre salut ne
pouvait venir que des forces de l'ordre.
À Mayote, contrairement à celles et ceux
qui pensent que nous ne sommes que des
sauvages, moi je dis que c'est
homootintus politicus. à Mayotte, on est
obsédé par la politique et souvent avec
une analyse très très fine des choses.
On est parfaitement conscient que étant
noir musulman, dans le trop du cul de
l'océan Indien, que personne ne sait
nous situer, on bénéficie pas d'une
réputation incroyable, mais plutôt qu'on
va nous coller à nous plein de poncifs
totalement racistes en disant les
machettes, c'est un peu votre histoire.
Vous êtes tous des sauvages, vous êtes
tous des sauvages. Et tous les tous les
amis que j'ai eu autour de moi, Mayotte
c'est la perle. Non non non non non. Il
y a il y a à Mayotte comme sur euh
beaucoup de territoires d'outreem, il y
a quand même tout un folclore en en dans
l'hexagone. Laissant penser qu'on est
des bons sauvages et que la violence est
inhérente chez les noirs. On va pas
rentrer là-dedans, ce qui est totalement
faux. Mais mais donc euh on sait que
s'il y a le moindre déchaînement de
violence à Mayotte, on nous l'imputera
et on ne cherchera pas à savoir pourquoi
et que donc on doit absolument nous
maîtriser et faire confiance aux
autorités parce que ça va se retourner
contre nous et que le discours qui est
propagé qui est de pas trop voir la ni
regarder la complexité ni de regarder la
question politique va être simplement de
nous renvoyer à une pseudoanimalité qui
fait que bon vous êtes tous en train de
vous entretuer, c'est normal. On est
tout à fait conscient de ça. On est tout
à fait conscient de ça. Donc nous pour
nous c'est capital qu'on maintienne un
étroit un état de droit même lorsqu'il
nous abandonne et qu'on se batte pour
que les autorités prennent conscience de
l'importance de nous protéger. Et c'est
c'est une situation qui est qui est qui
est paradoxalement
pour les hexagonaux qui ont jamais ce
type d'inquiétude, il y a pas un képi,
il y a pas un soldat, il y a pas un
gendarme, un policier à Mayotte qui
n'est pas le fruit d'un long combat
politique. Pour nous, on s'est battu
pour rester français, mais on s'est
battu aussi et surtout pour que l'État
se déploie à Mayotte et pour faire
avancer l'état de droit. Parce que le
bras de fer avec Paris, même si on est
français depuis 1841, qu'on s'est battu
pour le rester, le bras de fer à Paris,
c'est de dire "Vous nous sortez de
l'exception, vous nous sortez du
bricolage, on veut la France". Simple,
clair et précise, c'est pour ça qu'on a
voulu le département par exemple. Donc
plus de tribunaux. Euh euh
nous on veut pas de tribunaux
particuliers, on veut pas de règles
particulières parce que chaque fois que
vous entendez
bah la polygamie a été abolie depuis un
petit moment à Mayotte pour la
départementalisation.
On parle de la loi, la pratique est
autre. Mais je vais pas apprendre à
notre cher pays et aux différents foyer
du président Mitteran que il y a pas
besoin d'avoir une polygamie officielle
pour avoir de nombreux foyers. Vous
voyez
voilà fermeture de cette parenthèse si
vous voulez qu'on aille là-dessus mais
c'est pas le sujet.
Et la polyandriie ? Non, ça va.
La poliandré. Alors Mayotte est une
société matriarcale dans laquelle les
femmes sont chefs de famille et
possèdent le la maison, le foyer. Et ça
veut dire et c'est un féminisme
particulier parce qu'en fait les femmes
sont chefs de famille effectivement mais
surtout elles sont indépendantes
financièrement et elles n'ont jamais le
moindre risque qu'on leur prenne leurs
enfants. Pour moi qui suis féministe et
qui vit aussi dans l'hexagone, c'est
vrai qu'il y a des discussions ici qui
sont assez particulières. C'est le le
droit napoléonien, notre droit à nous
français, il est quand même très macho.
Et nous, nos tradition à Mayotte, elles
sont plutôt très féministes. Et en fait,
finalement euh Mayotte est toujours à
rebour de ce que les gens imaginent.
C'est une société musulmane dans
laquelle les femmes sont chefs de
famille. On est complètement euh à
contre-courant mais sur beaucoup de
choses de ce que les uns et les autres
imaginotte.
Pour une femme c'est le pied,
c'est extraordinaire. [rires]
Pour les hommes aussi, il paraît. Non,
non, mais Mayotte Mayotte est Mayotte
est une est un paradis. C'est une
chance. Je vous parle de notre enfer
mais effectivement je pourrais vous
parler très longuement de la beauté de
Mayotte
qui a une forêt primaire, la
campagne
qui a un lagon fermé.
Non, non, non. qui qui a une forêt par
l'insularité qui est particulière, qui
est un écosystème unique au monde qui
est un des hot spot hot spot de la
biodiversité selon plus beau spot de
monde,
un hot spot de biodiversité selon le GC
euh qui est le plus grand lagon fermé du
monde. Donc avec un écosystème très
particulier, sublime pour celles et ceux
qui ont la chance de plonger en apné ou
en bouteille. Mais vraiment, il faut
aller en mer à Mayotte, c'est une
chance, c'est un c'est un bonheur et
c'est une beauté. Nous, on a nos nos
croyances à côté de l'islam qui font
qu'on qu'on salue la majesté de la
nature qui est pour nous quasiment une
divinité qui est un peu sacrée et oui,
c'est vrai que Mayotte c'est sublime. Et
puis de vous en parler, voyez, ça me
donne ça me donne un cafard monstrueux
parce que la maison me manque.
Je suis sûr qu'ils vont vous regarder
là.
Euh pour tout vous avouer, j'ai
travaillé sur Mayotte il y a plus de 13
ans sur les répercussions d'une crise
financière sur les économies insulaires
et sur les flux migratoires sur les
économies insulaires comme vous avez
comme on a discuté un peu, vous savez
que j'ai été un peu bourlingué sur
l'île.
Euh, j'ai fait tout le spectre de
Mayotte du bidonville en passant par le
fonctionnaire, celui qui était dépêché,
le mec de la PAF qui vient passer ses
vacances depuis la réunion parce que
Mayotte, c'est très joli, des pigs,
c'est des meilleurs.
Vous avez déjà visité un centre de
rétention administratif à Mayotte ? Oui.
Qu'est-ce que ça donne maintenant 13 ans
après ? Alors euh le le centre
rétention, le centre de rétention
d'administr le CR de Mayotte, le centre
de rétention administrative de Mayotte
et euh euh
selon euh toutes celles et ceux qui ont
travaillé dans les CR euh le top du top
en la matière en France.
Bien joué
parce que voilà parce qu'il a été
totalement refait. Il est euh je sais
pas mais il est récent, il est euh c'est
le plus grand. Ah non non, c'est euh
impeccable. Enfin, c'est c'est euh
propre, aéré, euh
très bien organisé, très bien survillé,
très bien surveillé, mais surtout le CR
à Mayotte, c'est euh plus de 22000
reconduites à la frontière par an qu'
pour 25000 pour tout le pays. Ça veut
dire que les reconduites à la frontière
en France, elles sont faites
principalement à Mayotte, en grande
majorité à Mayotte. Donc le CR à
Mayotte, c'est une machine très très
bien huilée. C'est d'ailleurs
capacité d'accueil de combien de
personnes ?
Ah, je saurais pas vous dire de tête.
Euh je crois qu'ils sont peut-être 300
mais à vérifier, je suis pas certaine.
Je l'ai visité mais alors je vous avoue
que je suis pas une folle des chiffres.
Il y a toujours la lèpre à Mayotte où
c'est passé ? Oh ben ça va, ça vient non
? C'est un peu comme tout le reste. Nous
avec nos clandestins, on a le retour de
plein de maladies disparues qui
reviennent, qui repartent au gré de
l'arrivée de de personnes qui ne sont
pas vaccinées, qui n'ont aucun aucun
suivi médical et qui importent avec ell
oui des maladies disparues. aussi dans
les bidonvilles, les conditions de vie,
l'insalubrité est telle dans les
bidonvillees que il y a beaucoup de
maladies liées à la pauvreté, au manque
d'hygiène qui qui apparaissent et qui
prospèrent à Mayotte, qui font après
l'objet de campagne de la RS, des
autorités de santé. Oui. Oui. Il y a eu
il y a eu la lèpre, elle a disparu, elle
revient, il y a eu le choléra, elle a
disparu, elle revient. Enfin, c'est
honteux la tuberculose, des des choses
scandaleuses en 2023 de savoir qu'il y a
ça sur un territoire français et que
c'est c'est grave. C'est pas juste
l'arrivée des des migrants, c'est aussi
les conditions de vie.
Quand on a pas d'eau, quand on n pas
d'eau courante, quand il y a des
coupures d'eau, ça génère évidemment des
risques sanitaires. Si vous avez ne pas
avoir d'eau à Mayotte dans tous les
foyers, ça veut dire que vous prenez des
poubelles propres parce que c'est des
contenants plastiques, vous les
remplissez d'eau et puis après vous
allez faire votre douche avec ce qu'on
appelle une capque qui a un un bol comme
ça et puis vous lavez comme ça. pour les
personnes âgées, les bébés, les malades,
il y a il y a rien de particulier, hein.
Donc c'est c'est des conditions de vie
qui sont pas normales et et
effectivement ça pose des sujets de
santé publique.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà discuté avec
des réfugiés comoriens ou des migrants
illégaux comoriens appelez Vous les
appelez comment ? Des réfugiés ou des
des
Non, réfugiés c'est un statut légal,
c'est pas un migrant. Les migrants
peuvent être des réfugiés, mais un
réfugié,
voyez, un réfugié, c'est un terme légal
pour dire quelqu'un qui a droit à
l'asile. Il y en a quasiment pas à
Mayotte. Il y en a des surtout des
ressortissants. Les les demandeurs
d'asile à Mayotte sont seulement depuis
quelques années Comoriens. La grande
majorité des demandeurs d'asile à
Mayotte viennent des grands lacs. Les
Comoriens à Mayotte sont des migrants en
quête économique. Ça c'est pas des
réfugiés.
Vous avez discuté avec eux ? Bah oui,
vous vous les voyez tout le temps
[rires] puis ils sont partout. C'est pas
que vous vous levez le matin. Est-ce que
tu un micro confiance en confiance ?
C'est-à-dire on va échanger. Est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu' vous ont fait remonter ?
Pourquoi ils viennent à Mayotte ?
Pourquoi ils prennent les coissa qua ?
Pourquoi euh C'est dangereux de prendre
un coissa quassa ? Pourquoi ils viennent
à Mayotte ?
D'abord, il y a deux choses. Moi, je je
pas l'intention de consacrer du temps à
explorer les les motifs et désosser avec
vous le le discours des autorités
comoriennes et des individus. Non, non.
Et des individus parce qu'en fait c'est
un Non, non. Et c'est un c'est un
c'est un discours qui est repris parce
que c'est une construction. La migration
comorienne. Elle a pas toujours été
comme ça à Mayotte. Euh et euh il y a un
discours et puis il y a la réalité des
causes de la migration. Il y a d'abord
euh pour des des migrants comoriens euh
une situation médicale, c'est-à-dire
certains qui viennent parce qu'ils
veulent se soigner gratuitement
parce qu'à Mayotte, il y a des règles
particulières qui font qu'il n'y a pas
par exemple tout le système de prise en
charge des des patients étrangers qu'il
y a dans le reste du pays. À Mayotte,
non. Donc vous rentrez, vous êtes soigné
et puis vous ne payez rien. Donc ça
c'est quand même un appel d'air
formidable par exception parce que
normalement le droit s'applique à
Mayotte comme dans le risque du pays.
Donc il y a quand même cet attrait de
pouvoir être soigné gratuitement, de
recevoir des médicaments gratuitement.
Donc pour tous les malades chroniques,
pour euh celles et ceux qui ont des
handicaps lourds, ils viennent à Mayotte
et puis il bénéficient du système de
santé de protection sociale, même très
maigre mais déjà existant qui a à
Mayotte. Ça leur permet aussi d'accéder
au systèmes de prise en charge qui font
que si c'est très grave, ils sont
transportés à la Réunion ou dans
l'hexagone parce que voilà impératif de
de prendre en charge des patients. Donc
il y a une migration médicale, il y a
une migration euh pour l'éducation.
Comme le système d'éducation est
effondré au com, ces personnes viennent
pour scolariser leurs enfants. Euh et
puis euh surtout il y a le la
perspective d'obtenir des papiers
français, pas simplement le séjour.
c'est que à Mayotte, vous avez quand
même une prime à l'endurance. Si vous
restez suffisamment longtemps à Mayotte,
tôt ou tard, vous aurez un enfant sur
place qui vous permettra à terme d'avoir
des papiers, d'être régularisés et de
devenir français. Et c'est ça cette
migration, le fond de la migration
comorienne, c'est le la perspective
d'obtenir des papiers français. Et dans
la semaine, selon les statistiques de la
préfecture, les citoyens comoriens qui
obtiennent la nationalité française à
Mayotte, dans la semaine, ils quittent
le territoire et ils vont dans
l'hexagone. Souvent à Marseille.
[rires]
C'est pas une explication que vous
attendiez. Mais contrairement en fait en
fait je vous le dis parce que en fait ce
discours sur la misère comorienne laisse
penser qu'il y a pas de réflexion ou de
construction d'un projet migratoire.
Évidemment qu'il y a un projet
migratoire individuel. Évidemment que
personne ne prend la mer et va prendre
risquer sa peau dans un quissa s'il y a
pas une motivation forte. Mais ce qui ce
qui fait endurer pour les migrants
comoriens des conditions de vie qui sont
pire à Mayotte que chez eux parce que
vivent dans les bidonvillees alors que
chez eux ils ont une solidarité
familiale, ils ont un village, ils ont
des des constructions, ben c'est parce
que à terme ils sont gagnants. Ils sont
gagnants parce qu'ils ont des
infrastructures même pourries
d'éducation, ils ont des infrastructures
de santé et puis à terme ils auront des
papiers et pourront bénéficier une fois
qu'ils sont régularisés de certaines
prestations sociales. C'est ça le sujet.
Baladure.
Le visa baladure, c'est la France qui
dit à un moment il y a une frontière
entre Mayotte et les comorts. Donc vous
avez besoin d'un visa parce que sauf
erreur Mayotte ne fait les comorts ne
font pas partie de l'Union européenne ni
de la France. Donc en fait, il y a un
visa entre deux pays et que en fait
c'est aussi euh le le
la
l'objet de fixation des autorités
comoriennes, l'espèce de délire de
construction pour dire que ce serait la
cause de de de tous ces morts en mer et
de ces gens qui prennent le bateau. Moi,
je veux juste rappeler quelque chose. Il
y a une frontière entre Mayotte et
l'échor parce que les Comor sont
indépendantes, Mayotte est française.
Donc il y a une frontière.
Il y a pas d'accord de libre circulation
entre la France et l'échor donc il y a
un visa.
Voilà, c'est aussi simple que ça. Celles
et ceux qui vont contester ça doivent
nous dire dans quel cadre il y a eu un
cadre un un un accord de libre
circulation entre la France et les
comortes. Parce que sauf erreur, nous à
ma on a pas été informé. Donc il y a un
visa qui a été créé par le premier
ministre Baladur. Effectivement, on
vient de faire l'avocat du diable.
[raclement de gorge]
Vous avez écouté les arguments côté
comorien qui dit que Mayotte a toujours
été comorienne, que la France a volé
Mayotte, que la France a acheté Mayotte,
qu'on a pas demandé les à l'époque le la
vie aux gens qui étaient sur place,
quand il y a eu un référendum,
c'était l'intelligencia
anciennement malgache française malgache
qui a fait pression sur la population
locale pour que il y a eu un référendum
en faveur de la France et et qu'ensuite
c'est compliqué. Alors maillot,
ensuite c'est compliqué. C'est bien
résumé.
Et donc [rires] j'écoute les arguments
des deux côtés. Donc en 1871 la France
achète Mayotte
1841 pardon.
Mayotte est acheté par la France auprès
du sultan
Andrian Soui.
D'accord. Combien ça a été acheté en or,
en diamant, en kil de poisson ? 1000
1000 piastres. 1000 ou 1500 piastres.
Enfin,
je suis sûr que votre communauté pourra
pourra corriger, trouver le en fait
quand ça a été vendu quand ça a été
vendu
en fait en fait ce qui est complètement
hallucinant c'est que la période avant
1841 s'appelle la période des sultans
batailleurs. Il y a un sultan par île
sur les quatre îles de l'archipel des
comors et ces sultans s'affrontent
méthodiquement. Sultan batailleur. Ça
fait des siècles que personne ne peut
s'encadrer. Il n'existe pas d'unité
politique au com jus qu'à la période
coloniale 1946.
jusqu'à 1976 où il y a une
administration commune pour l'archipel
des comes. Construction coloniale pure.
Donc avant il y a pas d'unité
comorienne, ça n'existe pas. Il y a
Jazzel Kamar, les îles de la lune qui
sont l'archipel géographique, les comor
archipel géographique découvert par les
arabes Gel Kamar. Mais il n'y a pas
d'unité politique, ce sont les sultans
batailleurs. Andrian Soui est un sultan
d'origine malgache qui a pris refuge à
Mayotte grâce au système d'alliance
puisque la moitié de la population à
Mayotte est d'origine malgache. C'est
pour ça qu'à à Mayotte, on parle de
dialectes. qui est issu du swili
parce que la population est bantou et
vient du continent et il se sur
plusieurs plusieurs siècles quand même
hein et une partie de l'île parle
malgache parce que c'est une population
qui qui est originaire de Madagascar.
Donc il y a toujours eu des liens
historiques avec Madagascar et donc ce
sultan Andrian Soui après refuse la
Mayotte face aux véléités des voisins
qui sont à Enjinant Moellie et la grande
Comore qui déjà faisait suer la
population à Mayotte. Andrian Soui se
sent menacé le commandant Passo qui est
un commandant français passe par là et
là Andrien Souli demande la protection
de la France pour Mayotte.
Il y a un traité qui est validé par nos
autorités religieuses.
C'est très important. C'est-à-dire que
contrairement au discours de certains,
Mayotte a volontairement dès le départ
souhaité devenir française pour se
protéger de ses voisins. C'est quand
même intéressant que depuis 1841, on en
soit toujours là, hein, et que les uns
et les autres qui se réveillent avec une
pseudofraternité
pourrait quand même mentionner les
radiaas pour aller prendre de la
population maorise, la réduire en
esclavage, la vendre dans la traite
arabo-musulmane qui a eu lieu tout le
long de la côte de l'Afrique de l'Est.
Vous voyez, il y a des gens qui sont un
petit peu amnésiques comme ça euh parce
que quand même la grande Comore a été un
un gros marché avec la Tanzanie de
traite d'esclave, hein. Faut faut
rappeler quand même que dans notre
région, c'est pas peace and love, c'est
pas l'amour des bisous nours et que
quand on entend le grand discours assez
récent de fraternité pour nous, Maorèz
et Maoré, c'est au mieux comique sinon
du déni complet, un révisionnisme absolu
de l'histoire. Il y a pas de mystère sur
le fait que Mayotte soit française.
C'est nous qui avons décidé qu'il valait
mieux un patron qui est assez lointain
et qui nous protège du voisin qui est
extrêmement violent et conquérant.
Voilà. Donc cette histoire après s'est
développée assez lointain. C'est ça.
Bah oui parce que bon quand même ces
trois peletés de tendu hein les blancs à
Mayotte jusqu'à très récemment. Ils sont
ils sont très peu nombreux. Mong qui est
le terme qu'on utilise en sur toute
l'Afrique de l'Est pour désigner le
blanc à Mayotte. Effectivement, on dit
le Vasa à à Madagascar ou les oreilles à
la Réunion. À Mayotte, on parle du
Mzungu, le blanc. Il y a eu très peu de
mzungu à Mayotte jusqu'à très récemment.
Et donc la la vision que nous avons eu
nous à Mayotte de la colonisation est
très différente de celle qu'il y a pu
avoir par exemple aux Antilles ou encore
à la Réunion. Je ne dis pas que c'était
une partie de plaisir. Il y a eu le
travail forcé à Mayotte. On n' pas connu
l'esclavage par la France euh mais on
l'a quand même connu avec la traite
arabo-musulmane de 1 et de deux, il y a
eu le travail forcé
un système pas très éloigné de de
l'esclavage. Il y a eu des plantations
de sucre euh à Mayotte aussi. Donc euh
c'est pas euh on n'est pas dans
l'angélisme, mais le discours de dire
euh pour aller euh rapidement sur la
question que vous m'avez posé euh de
dire la la les comor s'estiment euh volé
euh je pense qu'en soit ça traduit le
problème qu'il y a entre Mayotte et nos
voisins. Nous n'appartenons pas au com
euh on
Oui.
Pourquoi l'ONU a fait des misères à la
France pendant des années sur Mayotte ?
Parce que dans les années pour pour Non
non mais pour pour comment dire
expliquer les choses. Donc de 1841
à nos jours, Mayotte est française mais
a connu de multiples statut
et
le reste des des îles de l'Archipel ont
été colonisées et administrées
séparément par la France.
Euh et ce n'est que de 46 à 67 76 que
Mayotte est administré avec les autres
îles des Comors. Et c'est le fondement
de la revendication comorienne qui dit
en se basant sur un des principes de la
décolonisation selon l'ONU, vous ne
pouvez décoloniser que sur les
frontières existantes et donc les comors
revendiquent Mayotte parce qu'à l'époque
c'était administré dans un seul et même
ensemble. Sauf que nous on dit oui mais
la décolonisation c'est le droit des
peuples à disposer d'eux-même. Nous
sommes un peuple, nous avons voté et
nous nous avons dit non à
l'indépendance. Et c'est ça
combien de pourcent ? Euh plus de 60 %
sauf erreur. Sauf sauf sauf que on nous
a posé la question à de multiples
reprises puisque là on monte dans les 99
parce qu'en fait il faut comprendre que
les années qui ont précédé
l'indépendance ont été des années de
très grande violence politique à Mayotte
de tentative de suggestion de Mayotte
parce que Mayotte a toujours été pro
française et que les autorités à Moroni
comme à Enjoin avaient compris que
Mayotte serait contre l'indépendance et
donc nous notre combat ça a toujours été
de dire À Paris, on veut un vote séparé
ou en tout cas un décompte séparé. C'est
ce qui a été contesté par les comorts à
l'indépendance et ce qui leur a servi de
revendication auprès de l'ONU. Les
condamnations de la France à l'ONU par
rapport à Mayotte sont à l'assemblée
générale. Ce ne sont pas des des
condamnations qui ont valeur, j'allais
dire euh qui qui ont un impératif
juridique qui ne sont pas des
condamnations qui induisent quoi que ce
soit au niveau international. C'est des
condamnations politiques sur une
assemblée générale qui compte
principalement des pays décolonisés,
donc qui sont nécessairement en
solidarité avec le discours des comorts.
Et il faut dire notre faute à nous,
Maores et Maoré, c'est de ne pas avoir
compris la portée de ce que ce discours
des comort à l'international. c'est de
ne pas avoir compris qu'en fait à un
moment il faudra qu'on explique notre
choix et que non d'avoir un seul et même
ensemble géographique, une communauté
culturelle ou linguistique ne faisait
pas un pays. Ce qui pour les autres pays
africains est tout à fait compréhensible
parce que les autres pays africains ont
eux aussi hérité de frontières qui ne
reflètent pas leur unité ethnique ou
leur destin politique. Donc ça, je pense
que c'est un champ qu'on a pas assez
investi, nous Maorz et Maoré et que ça
nourrit ce discours dans lequel nous on
ne se reconnaît pas du tout, qui est
véhiculé par les autorités comoriennes
qui laisse penser que
alors au mieux Mayotte est française
parce que on a rien compris à l'histoire
qu'on est victime du syndrome de
Stockholme. Nous Mauré parce qu'on est
très bête qu'en fait on n pas compris
qu'on était colonisé et que donc on a un
peu limité intellectuellement. Euh ça
c'est la version soft, mais sinon la
version quand même en en grand comorien
et en dialecte, c'est quand même de nous
dire qu'on est des vendus,
qu'on est un peu les prostituées de la
France. C'est ça le discours. Donc si
vous voulez, il faut quand même avoir
un peu de lucidité sur le discours
comorien parce que au fond si on
conteste si on conteste le vote qui a
permis que Mayotte reste française, on
conteste le vote de l'indépendance.
Si on va au bout, hein, si on nous dit
"Oui, le vote a été trafiqué". Bon ben,
il a été trafiqué pour tout le monde. De
1 2 de euh il y a eu d'autres votes et
Mayotte a continuellement réaffirmé son
attachement à la France. Est-ce qu'il
est possible démocratiquement de
rattacher une terre et un peuple à un
ensemble politique dont on refuse
absolument
de faire partie ? Comment est-ce que
démocratiquement et politiquement on
peut justifier en 2023 de vous mettre en
couple quand on a dit non ?
On en est où du consentement ? Pour
nous, c'est un viol total de nos
convictions et de notre combat et de
notre histoire. Et j'utilise ces termes
à dessin pour que tout le monde
comprenne ce que nous on ressent quand
on entend ça. On est doué de libre
arbitre. On a notre liberté de réfléchir
et de penser. On décide de notre destin.
Mayotte, on a décidé de notre destin. On
reste français. Et c'est pas
internationaux ou pas. Je vais terminer.
Non mais oui,
c'est pas que c'est pas que les comors
soient une success story, c'est pas
Singapour à côté. Juste qu'on soit un
peu clair, c'est un pays effondré.
C'est un pays qui est euh sinon une
dictature au moins ou très très
autoritaire. ou quand même le président
Azaliiste de son état général qui n'a
pas été élu a envoyé il y a quelques
armé la troupe et des requêtes sur la
population à enjoint.
C'est un pays qui est traversé de
séparatisme tellement fort qu'on a vu il
y a quelques années la population
joanaise demander le rattachement à la
France. Non, mais je veux dire, il faut
comprendre ce vers quoi ce discours nous
entraîne. C'est-à-dire que la grande
bonté, la générosité des uns et des
autres sur la planète, les quelques-uns
qui se penchent sur le sort de Mayotte
nous souhaitent d'aller rejoindre
ce qu'on pourrait très simplement
appeler un bordel général parce que
quand même les comor Ah bah si parce que
c'est un bordel parce que vous êtes avec
une succession de coup d'état,
c'est pas un dénigrement, c'est un
constat.
Vous êtes avec une succession de coup
d'état dans un état qui ne vit que des
subsides internationaux,
qui ne sait plus faire fonctionner ni
son eau, ni son électricité, ni ses
systèmes de santé, ni son système
politique qui ne vit que un peu au
continent, dites-moi.
Non, non, mais non, non, mais je je Non
mais quand même, il faut il faut juste à
un moment on va arrêter de se cacher
derrière son petit doigt.
Si vous êtes en train de me dire
Estelle, pourquoi est-ce que Mayotte va
pas rejoindre la Dubaï de du canal du
Mozambique ? Pourquoi est-ce que vous
êtes pas vous avez pas envie d'aller
vers le Singapour de l'Oscent Indien ?
Et là, vous pourriez nous dire vraiment
vous êtes difficile et compliqué. Mais
non, là on nous dit vous allez dans
l'état qui est au fin fond du trou qui
est au fin fond du trou de tous les
classements internationaux de corruption
de développement humain,
des petits problèmes qui durent depuis
l'indépendance. Ce qui nous fait nous
nous dire que nos anciens ont eu raison.
Non, non, mais ils ne récupèrent pas. Ça
voudrait dire qu'il l'
Pourquoi ils veulent ?
Alors c'est faut leur poser la question.
Je vais pas aller me répondre sur ce
qu'ils en veulent.
C'est leur faire trop de publicité.
Il y a des ressources à Mayotte. Quel
est le la l'aspect géopolitique,
géostratégique, géoénergétique de
Mayotte ? [rires] Est-ce que par exemple
grâce à Mayotte, on peut contrôler le
canal du Mozambique ? Est-ce que grâce à
Mayotte, on peut avoir une station
d'écoute sur place ? Est-ce que grâce à
Mayotte, on aurait accès à un domaine
maritime qui aurait potentiellement du
gaz ? Est-ce que grâce à Mayotte, on
pourrait avoir un œil dans l'océan
Indien ?
Ah, vous répondez à toutes vos
questions.
Non, je vous laisse [rires] faire.
Non, pas du tout. Euh
je pense que euh c'est dommage parce que
vous n'avez pas de cartes mais je suis
sûr que votre communauté en aura une.
Ça c'est certitude. En fait en fait
alors que en 2023 la France est virée
manu militar du continent,
la terre la plus africaine de France
c'est Mayotte qui est à quelques
centaines de kilomètres du continent
avec une population française qui parle
soi qui est proche culturellement de
l'Afrique qui est dans le canal du
Mozambique qui est une des routes
maritimes les plus empruntées mais
surtout le plan B quand Le canal de Suè
est fermé.
Le canal du Mozambique, c'est
aujourd'hui euh les deuxè plus grosse
réserve de gaz naturel qui grâce aux
avancées technologiques sont rentables.
Il y a toujours eu ces réserves de gaz
mais en fait avec les avancées
technologiques et surtout la hausse des
cours du gaz, ça devient rentable et
nécessaire
et surtout avec la guerre avec la
Russie.
Exactement. C'est-à-dire que c'est
d'autant plus nécessaire qu'avec la
guerre en Russie.
L'Europe a pris conscience de
l'impératif
la pardon la la guerre en Ukraine et des
difficultés avec la Russie. L'Europe a
pris conscience de l'impératif de
diversifier ses sources
d'approvisionnement en gaz naturel.
Alors, pour qu'on soit complet, les
contrats sur l'exploitation dans
principalement au Mozambique, dans les
eaux mozzambiennes, ces contrats parce
que les contrats de gaz sont des
contrats pluriannuels, les premières
productions de gaz iront vers l'Asie.
Mais évidemment le le l'objet pour tous
les investisseurs qu'il y a dans ces
champs gaziers euh au Mozambique, au
large du Mozambique et donc au large de
Mayotte, euh c'est euh que à terme
l'Europe puisse récupérer une partie de
de ce gaz naturel. Il faut comprendre
que le canal le canal du Mozambique, ce
sont certes des eaux mozzambiennes, des
eaux tanzaniennes, des eaux malgaches,
mais il y a aussi beaucoup d'eau
françaises avec Mayotte, mais avec les
îles éparses, les tafs, c'est-à-dire
toute une série de de zones économiques
exclusives qui permettent des droits de
pêche, qui permettent que notre marine
nationale puisse voguer explorer,
écouter, peut-être s'entraîner souvent
euh travailler, on va dire ça comme ça.
C'est-à-dire qu'on exerce notre
souveraineté sur ce canal dans une zone
qui est très contestée. La une grosse
partie de l'empreinte maritime de la
France, c'est l'océan Indien, c'est le
canal du Mozambique et c'est là où se
concentre tous les conflits territoriaux
que la France peut avoir. On est en
conflit territorial avec les Comor
Mayotte est le seul territoire français
habité contesté. On est en conflit avec
l'île Maurice pour Tromelin. On est en
conflit avec Madagascar pour les îles
éparses. Et donc
Mayotte, même si la France pense son
océan Indien avec la Réunion
principalement mais qui est de l'autre
côté de Madagascar et Mayotte. Mayotte
est la seule île qui est habitée
française qui est dans ce canal du
Mozambique qui il y a quelques années
se résumé dans dans le cerveau de
beaucoup de nos décideurs ici à ça sert
pas trop à rien le continent voué à sa
perte. ce gaz là restera sous l'eau
parce qu'il ne sert à rien, parce qu'on
peut pas l'exploiter. Et puis en fait
cette crise énergétique européenne, les
avancées technologiques mais aussi mais
aussi la l'imp la la l'impératif
de sécurité par rapport à
l'approvisionnement en métau rar et avec
les nodules marins qui sont sous ces ces
comment dire sous ces fonds marins
font que la région devient importante.
C'est-à-dire que toute cette économie
bleue qui paraissait l'économie bleue
c'est celle qui part des ressources
aliotiques au nodules marin à toutes les
avancé scientifiques qui peut y avoir en
mer.
C'est joli économie bleu
c'est un peu économie verte
ça restait ça restait un peu abstrait
mais en fait la technologie a avancé nos
besoins se sont accrus et donc le canal
du Mozambique et Mayotte la belle
oubliée de la France devient subitement
beaucoup plus sexy. Le problème c'est
qu'on paye des années d'abandon. et des
années d'oubli, des années de
sous-investissement, des années où on a
un peu laissé tomber notre défense de
Mayotte. On a réduit la voilure au début
au niveau de notre présence militaire
dans l'océan Indien et puis bon quand
même on avait une logique où on se
disait c'est dou tout cuit on a jibouti.
Bon si on veut sécuriser la France elle
est tranquille on est chez nous à
Dibouti. Bon indépendance puis après on
se disant mais quand même on reste chez
nous puis après bon bah les jibousiens
on fait monter les enchères. On a
accueilli les Chinois, on a accueilli
les Américains, il y a beaucoup de monde
àouti. Donc au final au final Mayotre
devient très très importante
stratégiquement.
Oui.
J'ai eu la chance d'y aller.
J'ai eu la chance d'y aller lorsque
j'étais journaliste et je suis montée
sur un bâtiment de la marine nationale
pour chasser du pirate somalien en
reportage pour Aljazira. Et donc j'y
suis allée et effectivement
c'est c'est une c'est un c'est un
endroit captivant.
On va dire ça comme ça.
On reparlera de [rires] votre Ouais. On
reparlera de votre passage
journalistique un peu plus tard pour
[raclement de gorge] Mayotte.
Comment vous voyez l'avenir ? Est-ce que
les Est-ce que les reconductions à la
frontière sont prises ? Reconduite
les pardon les reconduites à la
frontière. Est-ce que les comor
récupèrent leur ressortissant ? Mais ça
c'est de l'avenir immédiat, c'est pas de
l'avenir.
Ouais. Non mais j'arrive. Comment vous
voyez avec le réchauffement climatique
des flux arrivés plus en on va dire de
un peu plus toufu fut le le flux ?
Est-ce que vous le voyez un peu plus
compliqué en terme d'approvisionnement
d'eau d'infrastructure ? Est-ce que il y
a une
je perturbé est-ce que ça réfléchit un
petit peu à comment Mayotte va survivre
pour les 30 prochaines années avec des
facteurs de soutenabilité qui sont
compliqués ? Énergie, flux migratoire,
réchauffement climatique, problème d'eau
et j'en passe. Est-ce que le politique
français, est-ce que le gouvernement, on
va dire de Paris a pris en considération
tout ça ? Est-ce que vous avez quand
même peur que la France en crise
économique, que la France en guerre, que
la France n'a plus de moyen pour assurer
la sécurité de Mayotte, infini, vous
vous retrouviez
à Mayotte un peu seul au monde.
Alors euh
et on parlera du droit du sol après.
Je ne me suis pas engagée pour être
défétiste.
C'est pas défétiste. Non non non non,
pas du tout. C'est c'est pas ce que je
dis. Je je ne me suis pas engagée pour
être desfétiste. C'est-à-dire que ma
conviction, c'est qu'on ne peut que
sortir par le haut. Et notre histoire
avec un grand hach à Mayotte, c'est
qu'on s'est toujours sorti par le haut.
Ça veut pas dire qu'on n'est pas passé
très loin du précipice. C'est pas la
première fois dans notre histoire qu'on
observe les grands bouleversements du
monde et que contrairement à ce que
certains imaginent, ils ne nous
affectent pas. On est absolument
conscient he Mayotte du péril
géostratégique dans lequel se trouve la
France et aussi que les mouvements des
tectoniques des plaques au niveau des
grandes puissances nous affectent.
Mayotte et tout l'océan Indien est le
lieu de lutte d'influence très
importante. L'influence russe,
l'influence chinoise, l'influence des
pays arabes du golf, l'influence euh de
de l'Inde aussi. C'est-à-dire que c'est
une toute petite zone c'est une toute
petite zone où vous avez beaucoup
d'appétit. Ça se manifeste par les
investissements dans les champs gaziers.
avec des groupes concurrents. Ça se
manifeste avec par exemple il y a
quelques semaines des exercices
militaires qui conjoint entre les
marines
russe, chinoise, sud-africaine à
quelques
miles de maillotes et des marines
françaises,
américaines et britanniques qui se sont
mobilisé avec les marines kenianes pour
qu'il y ait euh si vous voulez une
espèce de de petite de petits, comment
est-ce qu'on pourrait dire ça ?
Manifestation de de l'existence des uns
et des autres. On se renifle, on se
regarde, on se défie. Mais nous
population qui vivons au milieu de ces
menaces, c'est pas une abstraction.
C'est-à-dire que d'ici, on on a
l'impression que c'est bataille navale,
touché coulé, machin. Pas du tout. Nous,
on voit passer ces bâtiments de guerre.
On voit sur nos réseaux sociaux les
dirigeants de pays adversaires, de pays
hostiles à Mayotte française qui se
gargarise de du soutien de Moscou, du
soutien de la diplomatie chinoise. Et on
comprend bien que notre pays est
questionné dans sa légitimité à Mayotte
et agressé par rapport à sa
souveraineté. Donc pour nous, c'est pas
du tout une abstraction. Par contre,
c'est là où nous un Mayotte, on essaie
comme tous les petits
pays arables, vous parliez des quel type
d'influence ?
Comme tous les pays, comme tous les
petits euh les petits territoires, nous
c'est jamais par la force que Mayotte
peut survivre. Mayotte ne peut survivre
que par son intelligence ou
par sa défense.
Non, Mayotte ne peut survivre que par
son intelligence. Une fois ce qu'on t'a
posé de toutes les concurrences dans la
région, le sujet pour nous, c'est de
nous rappeler au bons souvenirs de nos
dirigeants en disant "Attention, on est
là et on est utile."
C'est pas une question de supplique,
c'est pas une question de faire la
mendicité pour obtenir le soutien de
notre pays. C'est de dire "On est
stratégique. On vous rappelle que nous,
territoire français du canal du
Mozambique, qui n'avons jamais mis en
doute notre appartenance à la France,
qui engage nos fils, nos filles dans les
rangs de l'armée parce qu'il y a de très
nombreux maoré qui servent le drapeau.
Nous, on se défendra pour notre pays et
on est là pour servir de base pour la
marine nationale, pour la Légion
étrangère et qu'on a besoin non
seulement pour notre protection mais
aussi pour la projection de la force de
la France dans le canal du Mozambique.
Donc non seulement on a conscience des
risques mais on sait aussi qu'on ne peut
que sortir par le haut. Donc
effectivement ce que vous évoquez sur
l'avenir de Mayotte, il y a plusieurs
sujets. D'abord,
on s'accroche on s'accroche à la France
comme une moule à son rocher parce que
ça tangue, parce que notre pays doute de
sa puissance et de sa place sur la scène
internationale et que pour nous, ça a
des conséquences immédiates parce que on
doit euh
réargumenter notre importance dans la
stratégie indo-acifique de la France.
parce que Paris regarde beaucoup vers le
Pacifique et oublie la partie indo. Donc
nous, on doit rappeler que dans cet arc
indo pacifique, la naissance c'est le
canal du Mozambique ou c'est nous ?
C'est une partie qui est très
importante. Euh rappelez que nous sommes
adossés à un continent qui est le
réservoir de croissance du prochain
siècle, que la Chine, elle est déjà en
décroissance démographique, qu'elle est
en train de décélérer au niveau de sa
croissance et que le continent qui est
toujours en croissance et qui sera
toujours en croissance sur le siècle à
venir, c'est l'Afrique.
C'est ça la réalité de de des
projections et et de l'évolution sur le
siècle qui vient. Donc Mayotte a
beaucoup de cartes à jouer. Est-ce que
c'est une partie facile ? Certainement
pas parce que les contraintes sont
importantes et vous avez tout à fait
raison de mentionner la question du
changement climatique.
Mayotte, c'est je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure, un hot spot de la biodiversité
selon le JC, c'est un un hotspot de
vulnérabilité aussi. C'est-à-dire que
nous, on a une petite combinaison assez
gratinée d'un volcan sous-marin qui
pousse dans notre lagon qui fait que
notre île s'enfonce et avec le
réchauffement climatique, on a une
montée des eaux. Donc nous, on a un
risque imminent, euh très pressant, je
le dis avec le sourire, mais qu'en fait
est une vraie catastrophe parce que 80 %
de la population à Mayotte vit sur euh
le le rivage. Donc en fait, nous la
montée des eaux et on le voit avec les
grandes marées, on a on perd on perd
beaucoup très vite de la surface
habitable et et et les eaux montent
assez rapidement à Mayotte. On a ce
sujet-là donc la montée des eaux, elle
menace la vie à Mayotte. les zones
habitées de 1, on a un sujet par rapport
euh au au changement climatique qu'on
observe déjà, c'est-à-dire que les
routes des cyclones se sont déplacées
dans le canal du Mozambique. C'est ce
que vous avez vu vous par les
informations avec l'accélération du
nombre de cyclones extrêmement
destructeur ou mozzambique donc sur la
côte. Avant ces cyclones, moi j'ai 44
ans. Ces cyclones il passaient à Mayotte
et en fait depuis plus d'une décennie il
ne passe plus à Mayotte et cette route
s'est déportée euh vers l'ouest. Ça veut
dire moins de plusiométrie pour Mayotte
et ça veut dire aussi que notre
végétation change. Ça veut dire un
changement de cycle pour la production
agricole. Ça veut dire des difficultés
pour nous alimenter. Le deuxième volet
de cette question migratoire et vous le
savez avec la sécheresse que vous
observez au Madagascar,
c'est que les zones qui étaient riches
au niveau agricole, qui étaient
autosuffisantes
commencent à disparaître dans toute la
partie australe de l'Afrique.
On le voit pour la corne de l'Afrique,
c'est les familles en répétition. Euh
mais en fait, on voit aussi sur la
partie australe que on a des grosses
perturbations et donc des flux
migratoires qui sont de plus en plus
important. Donc nous on voit déjà et on
on press, on sait qu'on va avoir un
afflux migratoire sur la zone. Bon,
l'État travaille avec des projets de
coopération régionale. Moi, je ne pense
pas qu'il soit possible d'enjamember les
questions de souveraineté et de conflits
territoriaux qu'à la France dans la
région pour travailler sur la
coopération régionale. La crise avec les
comorts est le plus l'exemple le plus
criant. Mais la France peut pas
travailler avec Madagascar ou avec
Maurice en faisant comme s'il y avait
pas de conflits territoriaux. Sur la
question de la France dans l'océan
Indien, on ne peut pas envisager une
relation normale, saine, constructive
avec nos voisins si on narrive pas à
apaiser et à écluser les sujets
territoriaux, les sujets coloniaux. Et
donc cette question de savoir comment
est-ce que ensemble on peut faire face
aux enjeux climatiques, comment est-ce
qu'on peut faire face aux enjeux
migratoire pour moi ça passe par des
solutions politiques impératives. Mais
pour revenir sur la question parce que
je sais que je suis très longue, j'ai
toujours pas répondu. [grognement] Les
flux migratoires évidemment on en aura
beaucoup. Oui, j'ai vu ça. J'apprécie,
je salue, je remercie.
Les flux migratoires, évidemment, on en
aura de plus en plus à Mayotte. Le sujet
c'est comment est-ce qu'on les gère ? Et
ça c'est pas qu'une question pour
Mayotte, c'est une question pour tout
notre pays. C'est-à-dire que si on va
pas avoir une réflexion
nationale et ensuite européenne et
ensuite mondiale sur ce qu'on fait des
flux euh qui sont des êtres humains qui
vont d'un point à un autre.
On parle de flux migratoire mais ce sont
à chaque fois des personnes qui quittent
leur foyer et qui vont ailleurs et qui
s'assoit sur le principe de frontière
qui peuvent instrumentaliser le droit
qui vont se présenter en réclamant
l'asile et donc un certain nombre de
prestations sociales et de protection
alors qu'en fait elles sont en migration
économique. Et en fait le débat
politique c'est non seulement comment on
organise l'accueil
mais aussi comment est-ce qu'on pense le
statut de ces migrants climatiques.
Est-ce qu'on parle de réfugiés
climatique ? Si on parle de réfugié
climatique, on ouvre des droits
automatiques parce que ce sera l'asile
climatique.
Ou alors on dit non, c'est une migration
et en fait on choisira, on donnera ou
pas certains droits et c'est une autre
discussion politique. Nous finalement ce
qu'on voit à Mayotte, il y a le volet de
la revendication territoriale. À
l'évidence, les Comor instrumentalisent
les flux migratoires pour asseoir leur
revendication. Mais il y a aussi
effectivement une migration qui vient,
on le voit par exemple avec l'arrivée de
migrants de Madagascar qu'on avait pas
vu avant à Mayotte qui eux arrivent et
c'est récent mais c'est de plus en plus
important et c'est à l'évidence liée à
la sécheresse qu'on observe dans le sud
de la grande île. Ça c'est clair. Et si
on voit les projections sur les
prochaines décennies en terme de flux
migratoire et de changement climatique,
on aura nous à ma de plus en plus de
flux. Donc le sujet c'est est-ce que on
organise enfin une solidarité nationale
avec le reste du pays qui prendra sa
part du fardeau migratoire ? Euh je je
vois que vous êtes pas convaincu, mais
en fait ce sera pas possible de laisser
Mayotte devenir une cocotte minute. On
va pas pouvoir faire face. Il y aura
sinon des violences. C'est évident parce
qu'on a atteint le seuil de
l'acceptabilité sociale. La population
amot ne l'accepte plus.
Et il y a déjà eu dans l'histoire des
massacres à Zanzibar ou à Madagascar
contre les populations comoriennes qui
étaient en migration là-bas. Donc nous
historiquement dans la région, on sait
que ça peut arriver.
Il faut pas que ça arrive.
Ça ne peut pas arriver. Ça ne doit pas
arriver si on prend les réponses
politiques adéquates. C'est pas une
menace que je dis. C'est quelque chose
qui est à nous tous dans nos mémoires.
Que ce soit au Comor, que ce soit à
Madagascar, en Tanzanie ou à Mayotte.
à la France, à l'Europe,
on sait on sait que cette question
d'acceptabilité, elle est fondamentale.
Quand vous avez une population étrangère
qui arrive sur un territoire à Forceori,
un territoire insulaire, vous avez
toutes les infrastructures qui sont
mises sous pression, que ce soient les
infrastructures scolaires, sanitaires ou
de production d'eau ou de production
d'électricité. Le foncier est mis sous
pression. La capacité à nous alimenter,
à importer suffisamment d'alimentation
et sous pression. par un système assez
simple. Aujourd'hui, on assiste à un
déboisement massif de Mayotte, une
déforestation. Les migrants arrivent,
ils ont besoin d'espace pour
s'installer. Ils coupent la forêt
primaire, ils déboisent.
Ils déboisent parce qu'en plus ils
veulent créer des champs.
Donc en fait vous diminuez l'espace
naturel sauvage, vous détruisez
l'écosystème.
Ce déboisement entraîne des coulés de
bout qui vont asphyxier le lagon qui par
ailleurs le lagon est notre regard de
manger.
On tue la réserve aliotique,
on tue aussi la manguve.
On tue on tue la mangrove qui sert de
protection en cas de tsunami.
Je je vous renvoie à la question de la
montée des eaux qui pose un sujet.
Tsunami et cyclone qui sont de plus en
plus importants lorsqu'il y a le
phénomène de réchauffement climatique.
Si vous voulez, on a tout un effet euh
domino qui peut être qui est déjà
catastrophique pour Mayotte.
La la migration est un écoside.
C'est c'est grave de dire ça, mais c'est
une réalité. Et de fait, c'est une
machine infernale qui nourrit les
migrations parce que l'île ou les
territoires n'arrivent plus à nourrir
leur population, les populations partent
et ça et ça alimente un un cycle
migratoire infernal. Donc cette
question, elle ne peut pas évidemment
être réglée par Mayotte seule. Il faut
non seulement une prise de conscience
pour le reste du pays, mais avec une
solution qui est européenne. Moi, j'ai
eu la chance dans le cadre de mes
missions pour l'Assemblée nationale au
sein de la commission des affaires
étrangères de m'emparer d'un rapport
pour lequel je suis corapporteur sur les
enjeux migratoires aux frontières sud de
l'Union européenne et dans l'océan
Indien. Et donc nous sommes allés voir à
Mayotte, mais aussi en Grèce et en
Italie la réalité pour ces territoires
qui sont à la frontière avec l'Afrique
de l'impact migratoire. Et en fait ce
qu'on observe c'est que autant pour moi
quand je vais à Lampéa ou quand je vais
en Grèce c'est une situation comparable
à celle de Mayotte autant nous notre
pays ne se vit
comparable ou pire
comparable
pas pire parce que en fait les autorités
grecques et italiennes elles ont pris
conscience et elles ont pris des mesures
et elles ont pris elles ont pris elles
ont pris des mesures à à en Italie et en
Grèce pour qu'il y ait la solidarité
européenne et la solidarité nationale.
et elles ont réorganisé l'accueil des
des migrants dans ces deux dans ces deux
zones alors que nous à Mayotte la France
est dans le déni absolorganisé comment
c'est c'est de
rétentionux je veux commencer par là
c'est que nous nous pour moi ma je vais
à l'empéusa pour moi maorise je vais à
l'empéusa je vais en Grèce je vois des
situations semblables à celles que je
connais sur mon territoire la grosse
différence c'est que Athènes et Rome ont
pris conscience du problème. Paris non
Paris quand je vous dis
quand je vous dis l'empéusa et la Grèce
Lampéusa ou l'esbos sont des situations
semblable à Mayotte personne ici ne
l'accepte à Paris et donc on ne prend
pas les mesures adéquates. Ça veut dire
que quand on on se dit pour nous
européens il faut créer des centres
d'accueil avec des camps pour accueillir
les migrants, ça nous renvoie à un passé
insupportable. Ça nous renvoie
évidemment au camp de concentration, au
camp d'extermination. C'est
insupportable. Pour autant, moi je vous
dis Maise, quand on n'organise pas
l'accueil des migrants, on crée des
bidonvillees qui sont des zones
indignes, violentes, insalubres,
dangereuses.
Donc c'est pour les centres de rétention
administrative.
C'est pas que les cras, c'est plus que
ça. C'est plus que ça. Parce que en fait
à partir du moment où vous dites une
personne en situation irrégulière, je
n'organise pas son accueil, je les
laisse s'installer sur le territoire,
vous alimentez toute une économie
clandestine. Vous alimentez le trafic
humain, vous alimentez le travail
illégal, vous alimentez cette économie
souterraine qui est en fait en train de
déstabiliser totalement les territoires.
Et ça, il faut prendre conscience. que
contrairement à ce qu'on pense en se
disant c'est inhumain envers les
migrants, non seulement c'est plus
humain d'organiser l'accueil et de
construire les infrastructure
nécessaires,
qui ressemble plus à des prisons qu'à
autre chose,
qui ressemble à des prisons parce que ce
sont des zones de rétention, c'est
évident parce que si vous si vous allez
au bout de la logique de dire que vous
êtes dans un dans une entrée qui est
illégale, vous ne pouvez pas dire "Je
ferme les yeux, j'ai rien vu, rien
entendu" et puis on laisse faire. Parce
qu'en fait à Mayotte, on a laissé faire,
on ne peut pas gérer, on n'arrive plus
parce que l'anarchie
appelle le chaos. La nature humaine,
elle est ce qu'elle est. Si vous n'avez
pas de règle, ben vous vous allez dans
la bordélisation absolue et nous, on est
dedans à Mayotte. Et donc celles et ceux
qui dénoncent les les camps qui peut y
avoir en Grèce ou en Italie doivent
venir à Mayotte pour voir ce que c'est
quand on organise pas l'accueil. C'est
pas possible et on va au devant de
violence. Les Grecs et les Italiens ont
construit ces camps parce qu'il y a eu
des violences contre les migrants.
Ils se sont pas levés le matin avec des
volontés concentrationnaires. Pas du
tout. C'est que l'afflux a été tel dans
ces dans ces zones pas volonté
concentrationnaire. Non mais mais oui
mais c'est le discours qu'on entend dans
les la bouche des associations de
protection des droits des étrangers en
disant que c'est inhumain de vouloir
construire des des zones d'accueil et en
disant regardez ce qu'on fait les Grecs
qui ont été accusés comme les Mauré
d'être des xénophobes. Sauf que il y a
eu des affrontements, des violences
extrêmement graves entre les migrants et
les populations grecques parce que
c'était devenu des zones de non droit
avec des agressions que les indigènes,
les locaux ne pouvaient plus, n'avaient
plus accès à leurs propres
infrastructures et que les Grecs, moi je
suis allée sur le terrain, je suis allé
les rencontrer, j'ai discuté avec les
autorités, avec les habitants, ils ont
accueilli, tenté plus. C'est ce que nous
on a fait à Mayotte. Et puis au bout
d'un moment, on n'y arrive plus parce
qu'on est submergé, parce que il y a
toujours plus de misère humaine qui se
déverse et que en fait on n'y arrive
plus. Et donc c'est impératif qu'il y
ait cette prise de conscience au niveau
national.
Quand on entend euh sur le territoire
dans la métropole, Mayotte est un
laboratoire.
D'abord, on n'est pas des hamsters.
Merci. Bah oui. Bah oui. Mais en fait,
c'est très désagréable d'entendre ça. Je
vais vous dire, c'est un terme qui me
qui m'oripile parce que ça voudrait dire
que nous on est on est des des des
petits êtres qu'on va observer comme si
on avait pas ni le droit de vote, ni une
conscience, ni de sentiments. Non, on
n'est pas des laboratoires. Mais
fermeture cette parenthèse,
pas des hamsters. N'est pas d'amstè ni
des cochons d'inde. [grognement]
Et donc quand vous entendez ça [rires]
depuis la métropole, quand vous entendez
des gens qui disent voilà bah là avec
moi bouchou il y a il y a il y a des
gamines qui ont pas pu passer l'oral du
bac parce qu'elles sont fait déloger à
coup de pelleteuse.
Quand il y en a un qui pilotait sa
pelleteuse, un moment il était il s'est
retrouvé devant sa case, il a fait une
syncope parce que il a fait un malaise
de de devoir des des
caser.
Cette misère là, elle est prise comment
sur le territoire français à Mayotte ?
Est-ce que les gens sont relogés dans de
bonnes conditions ? Où ça ? Quelle est
capacité d'accueil ? Est-ce que ça a été
anticipé ? Comment ça se passe ? Ceux
qui sont sans papier, est-ce qu'ils sont
à la pelleté ? il passe du bus au
tribunal au tribunal dans le bus et dans
le bateau et reconduit. Comment ça se
passe ? Est-ce qu'il y a de la dignité,
de l'humanité ? Comment on gère ça sur
place ?
Alors les les les destructions des
bidonvillees se font dans le cadre de la
loi. Les relogements sont offerts à
celles et ceux qui y ont droit. C'est
pas quelque chose d'automatique. Si vous
êtes en situation Si vous êtes en
situation irrégulière, vous êtes
voué à être expulsé du territoire. Donc
les personnes qui sont je je termine mon
cher si vous voulez pas très cher
pardon. Donc s'il y a des gens qui sont
là depuis plus de 20 ans,
ils vont se faire reconduire euh comme
ça.
Si vous n'avez pas de papier, que vous
êtes en situation irrégulière, vous êtes
expulsé parce que vous occupez
illégalement un terrain. C'est pas parce
que vous avez volé depuis 20 ans que
c'est devenu votre propriété. C'est un
terrain qui appartient soit à une
collectivité, soit à une famille qui
paye des impôts, qui est allée au
tribunal pour récupérer son bien pour
lequel elle a euh payé ou qu'elle a
acheté ou dont elle a hérité.
Mayotte, c'est pas euh l'île du bon
Sauvage Rinon Cruzo Zoé et ça
n'appartient à personne. Il y a pas 1 cm
carré à Mayotte qui n'a pas de
propriétaire.
C'est c'est d'ailleurs un foncier qui
vaut extrêmement cher.
Donc celles et ceux qui occupent
illégalement des terrains en
construisant des bidonville ont volé ces
terrains. C'est du recel. Je je moi je
refuse d'entendre ce discours de de
misérabilisme. C'est c'est nier
totalement que ces terrains ont des
propriétaires. Ils ont des propriétaires
qui sont allés en justice, qui ont payé
des frais d'avocats. Les familles Maores
ne sont pas des familles riches. C'est
une famille qui a mis en commun toutes
ces économies pour payer un avocat et
des frais d'avocat hors de prix pour
récupérer son bien et obtenir son
terrain. Et quand l'État daigne
mobiliser la force publique pour faire
une décision, exécuter une décision de
justice, vous avez des ordes d'avocats
qui débarquent de l'hexagone pour se
donner bonne conscience, aider leur
étranger, aller au tribunal, engorger
notre désert judiciaire avec 90 % des
affaires à Mayotte concernent le droit
des étrangers parce que là-dedans, les
associations de défense des étrangers
considèrent à juste titre à Mayotte que
dans la masse des étranger, il y aura
bien un cas d'école qui fera
jurisprudence et qui fera avancer le
droit des étrangers pour le reste du
territoire national. Parce que c'est ça
la réalité à Mayotte, c'est que nous
justice fiable, on n' pas accès au
tribunal parce qu'il est engorgé pour
des affaires qui concernent des
étrangers pour faire avancer le droit
des étrangers. La réalité à Mayotte,
c'est qu'on est dans une concurrence
entre le droit du national, du
ressortissant
français qui n'a pas accès à ses propres
infrastructures,
qui n'a pas accès à ses propres services
publics, qui sont monopolisés par une
population étrangère en situation
irrégulière qui ne contribue pas au
frais de ces services publics. Parce que
par définition, le clandestin ne paye
pas d'impôts, ne participe pas au frais
de de de la collectivité.
C'est ça qui est insupportable quand
vous êtes comme dans l'hexagone avec
peut-être un pourcentage en de ça de 10
% de population, il y a aucun territoire
qui a plus de 50 % de la population qui
est étrangère en situation irrégulière
comme c'est le cas à Mayotte. à Mayot,
vous avez quand vous êtes à la table des
services publics, une personne sur deux
n'a pas payé pour ces services publics,
ne paye pas d'impôts, n'a pas contribué
à développer tout un monde parallèle où
vous allez vous ponner sur le
l'approvisionnement en électricité.
C'est produit comment d'ailleurs ?
Vous vous c'est une usine avec du fiou
et bientôt peut-être un petit peu de
renouvelable avec de l'éthanol. Bon,
c'est toute une discussion parce que
l'inténol va être importé. Enfin bon,
bref, mais sur la question de de
comprendre de quoi il s'agit,
l'illégalité de de ces personnes quand
on me dit "Oui, on va les reloger." Je
voudrais qu'on décortique un petit peu
de quoi on parle. On parle de personnes
qui sont arrivées, qui illégalement
entré sur un territoire, qui vont
s'installer illégalement sur un terrain
qui ne leur appartient pas. Elles vont
euh payer de l'argent souvent à des
marchands de sommeil parce qu'elles font
l'objet de beaucoup de trafic. Elles
vont payer de l'argent aux trafiquants.
Donc ces personnes ont de l'argent parce
que [grognement] vous payez pas rien.
Vous payez beaucoup de frais pour
rentrer illégalement à Mayotte. Vous
payez beaucoup de frais pour y rester.
Donc ces gens n'ont juste pas d'argent
pour contribuer au service public.
Ces personnes ont de l'argent pour aller
payer les frais au niveau de la
préfecture pour demander des papiers
pour être régularisés. Ça coûte cher de
faire un dossier ces personnes.
Je sais pas mais en gros entre 300 et
800 €
ces personnes elles payent des frais
d'avocat et elle elles font des tontines
pour se faire régulariser.
Vous voyez ? C'est-à-dire une pauvreté
toute relative. Chaque foyer a ses
priorités. Ces personnes, elles
s'organisent pour monopoliser des
terrains qu'elles occupent illégalement
et ensuite elles se tournent vers les
associations quand elles sentent le vent
tourner et puis elles disent "Moi, j'ai
des droits." Pour nous, Maurè et Maoré,
ça veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire que
c'est la prime à l'illégalité. Ça veut
dire que vous dites serrez les dents,
entrez illégalement, occupez
illégalement. Si vous restez assez
longtemps, il y aura l'association de
service qui va venir, qui va vous aider
et on va retourner la loi pour vous
donner des droits.
J'ouvre une parenthèse.
Alors non, parce que parce que je vais
au bout de ce que ça veut dire. Ça veut
dire que on dit à ces gens, on va vous
reloger. Allons sur la question du
relogement. Je vous rappelle que ces
terrains illégalement occupés
appartiennent aux collectivités
publiques, c'est-à-dire que ces terrains
sont destinés à la construction des
logements sociaux.
Comment est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
construise des logements sociaux à
Mayotte si ces terrains sont occupés ?
Moi, je veux bien tout entendre. L'île,
elle fait 375 km². Elle est pas
extensible. Si vous avez ces terrains
occupés, vous pouvez pas construire
dessus en même temps. C'est simple. Donc
à un moment, il faut de la cohérence. Je
rappelle quand même que la loi, c'est la
loi du relogement, c'est pas que vous
occupez, on vous reloge. C'est pas ça.
Si vous êtes en situation régulière, que
vous justifiez de votre présence et de
vos droits, vous êtes logé
temporairement.
C'est ça la loi. Il y a un espèce d'abus
euh discursif de la part de ces
associations qui laisse penser que en
fait on doit à ces personnes d'être
relogées. Point. Non. On doit les
reloger temporairement.
Si les uns et les autres, les bonnes
âmes veulent les reloger, je les invite
à penser aux zones qui sont de plus en
plus inhabité dans l'hexagone et qui
attendent désespérément ces villages
qu'on repeuple. Moi, je voudrais pas
qu'on vous empêche de bénéficier de
cette migration et d'aller à votre bon
cœur aider les uns et les autres parce
que si vous voulez, c'est toujours 34 %
ou c'est plus ?
Oui, c'est 34 % recensé. H
Je vous ai coupé. Comment vous voyez
après votre expérience à Lampellousa et
ailleurs, comment vous voyez la position
européenne et française par rapport au
flux migratoire ?
Bon, la position Bah oui, parce que la
position européenne, ça voudrait dire
qu'il y en a une, en fait, il y en a
plusieurs euh totalement contradictoire.
La position française qui est très
claire, c'est d'une incohérence absolue,
c'est-à-dire qu'on n'est pas capable de
d'avoir une politique publique qui soit
comment dire
cohérente. Je vais vous parler d'un d'un
cas très simple mais qui est le cœur du
problème à Mayotte, c'est la situation
des enfants.
Donc en fait
vous savez que quand le droit du sol
signifie que quand vous naissez en
France de parents étrangers, vous avez à
terme la nationalité française.
C'est-à-dire que entre 0 et 18 ans, vous
n'êtes pas expulsable parce que vous
êtes potentiellement français. Mais vous
n'êtes pas français. C'est pas certain
que vous le deveniez.
ce que vous avez suivi. Vous naissez en
France de parents étrangers, entre
illégalement sur le territoire.
À 18 ans, vous pouvez potentiellement
devenir français. Pendant ces 18 ans,
vous n'êtes inexpulsable.
Mais vous êtes pas français.
Ces enfants sont en fait sans papier,
sans nationalité, non expulsable
et leurs parents
arguent de cet enfant pour ne pas être
expulsable.
Et ça c'est par exemple un des angles
morts de la politique de l'immigration
en France.
On ne statue pas sur le cas de ses
enfants. On ne peut pas les expulser.
Les associations ont construit tout un
discours pour dire que leur
scolarisation est obligatoire alors
qu'en fait c'est leur éducation qui est
obligatoire. Ce n'est pas la même chose,
leur instruction.
Et donc on est à Mayotte dans une
situation où vous avez des dizaines de
milliers d'enfants qui sont nés de
parents étrangers qui ne sont pas
français mais qui ne sont pas
expulsables, qui sont pourtant en
situation irrégulière et il y a un
espèce de nom manland au niveau du
statut légal de ses enfants, de ses
mineurs. Et aujourd'hui, on arrive à à
cette vague où on a toute une cororte,
une classe démographique d'enfants nés
de parents comoriens qui sont arrivés
petits à Mayotte, qui peuvent
éventuellement prétendre à la
nationalité, qui vont à la préfecture
dont le cas est examiné et qui en fait
ne remplissent pas les conditions de
l'obtention de la nationalité française.
Ces enfants, ces jeunes sont de plus en
plus nombreux. font maintenant l'objet
du combat de la Sima, du Jissi et cetera
qui disent "Mais en fait ce sont des
maoris. Euh c'est un peu l'équivalent
des dreamers qu'on a vu pendant les
années du mandat d'Obama, c'est-à-dire
des enfants qui sont en fait étrangers,
qui prétendent à la nationalité mais en
fait qui n'y ont pas droit tel que le
les textes existent. Mais les autorités
comoriennes ne veulent pas en entendre
parler. Elles ont fait ces jeunes ont
fait l'objet de discussion de
négociation avec les comors. Les comor
ne veulent pas en entendre parler. Et
pour autant, on est dans les limbes du
statut. On sait pas quoi en faire. Ça,
c'est une des incohérences du droit
français. Expliquez-moi pourquoi est-ce
qu'on narrive pas à déterminer que si
vous êtes mineur, que vous n'avez pas de
papier, euh normalement on ne peut pas
vous dire je ne peux pas vous expulser.
Comprenez, c'est quand même un impensé
dans la réflexion. C'est
notre notre enjeu pour nous législateurs
ou en tout cas pour moi qui suis à
l'Assemblée nationale à l'évidence ça va
ça va sortir dans les discussions dans
les prochaines années sur la question du
droit des étrangers sur la question
migratoire.
Question internet est-ce que sa position
politique est partagée par ses collègues
députés du groupe LOT Liot ? Nonot.
[rires]
Mais alors Liot n'est pas un groupe
politique, c'est un groupe
parlementaire. C'est-à-dire que nous
avons Charles Robin.
Bah oui, Charles Robin. Donc euh le
groupe Liot, liberté indépendant, autre
mè et territoire auquel j'appartiens à
l'Assemblée nationale est un groupe
parlementaire, c'est-à-dire que c'est un
groupe technique. Euh nous sommes une
vingtaine de députés qui se sommes
rassemblés. On n' pas une ligne
politique commune. Euh, il y a des élus
qui sont centristes, il y a des élus qui
sont socialistes, il y a des élus qui
sont comme moi, sans étiquette
politique. Euh et on s'est rassemblé
pour avoir euh en fait du personnel, du
temps de parole, euh des une place en
fait dans l'assemblée. Si vous êtes en
député indépendant, vous avez moins de
temps de parole. Vous ne participez pas
à la conférence des présidents à
l'Assemblée, vous n'êtes pas consulter
lors des négociations avec le
gouvernement et cetera. Donc il faut
être au minimum 15 députés pour
constituer un groupe parlementaire.
Alors la plupart du temps, le groupe
parlementaire est un groupe politique.
Donc c'est le groupe RN, le groupe
Renaissance, le groupe LFI. Mais nous,
notre groupe Liot n'a pas de ligne
politique. J'ai le soutien euh de
beaucoup de mes collègues, mais euh on
n' pas de lignes politique. Alors, il se
trouve que sur les sites d'information
et de statistiques politiques, notre
groupe Liot qui pourtant n'a pas de de
consigne politique est celui qui vote le
plus en cohérence, c'est-à-dire qu'on
est souvent aligné sur nos votes. Mais
en fait, c'est pas une instruction. J'ai
lu sur les réseaux sociaux que
vous chauffiez à blanc les maoris et que
résultat des courses, il bloquent
l'accès aux soins euh pour les les
sans papiers à Mayotte. Qu'est-ce que
c'est vrai ? C'est pas vrai ?
Alors, c'est me prêter c'est me prêter
beaucoup de
Est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui bloquent
l'accès aux soins à des gens sur l'île ?
les collectifs de citoyens, j'ai présidé
un collectif de citoyens pendant
plusieurs années. Les collectifs de
citoyens ont décidé euh
d'être en vigilance devant les
dispensaires et le CHM, l'hôpital à
Mayotte pour dénoncer le fait qu'une
partie de l'appel d'air migratoire est
organisée par la gratuité des soins qui
est organisé à Mayotte par exception. Et
en fait l'exigence de d'une partie de la
population c'est de dire on ne peut pas
avoir Wamboufou si on ne s'attaque pas à
tous les volets qui organisent et qui
orchestrent l'appel d'air migratoire.
Donc euh moi j'ai donné aucune consigne,
je ne chauffe pas à blanc qui que ce
soit. à Mayotte, on n pas besoin. Je
suis pas un chef de gang comme on
pourrait l'entendre dans la formulation
du propos que vous venez de tenir. Mais
pour le coup, je pense non mais non mais
pour le coup pour le coup je pense que
c'est très important de comprendre parce
que c'est
rare dans l'hexagone, c'est qu'en fait
nous on est une population qui est
extrêmement politisée.
À Mayotte, la politique à Mayotte, la
politique c'est une question de survie.
Vous savez, vous connaissez l'expression
quand on dit "Si vous qui vous occupez
de politique, c'est la politique qui
s'occupe de vous". À Mayotte, c'est une
réalité donc tout le monde est très
investi de 7 à 77 ans.
Ça vote quoi Mayotte ?
Ça vote beaucoup.
Ça vote quoi Mayotte [rires] ?
Ça vote Ça dépend aux élections mais ça
dépend aux élections. Ça dépend aux
quelles élections. Bah alors alors je
vais vous répondre. Non non non, je vais
vous répondre parce qu'en fait c'est
très intéressant.
J'espère bien.
Non non non, c'est intéressant parce que
en fait à la présidentielle les Maoré
vote RN et LFI. En élection locale il
n'y a aucun élu RN
et il y a pas d'élu LFI. C'est-à-dire
qu'on a un électorat qui est très précis
sur ces attentes. Les attentes des
maoris au niveau national, c'est
l'émission c'est l'émission régalienne.
Ça veut dire 60 % pour le RN environ et
le reste c'est du c'est du LFI. et euh
Renaissance a fait des scores
catastrophiques parce que on a estimé
que le président Macron avait lors de
son premier mandat trahi Mayotte et donc
sanction au niveau des urnes. Et de la
même manière, moi je suis issu de la
société civile, je n'ai aucun parti et
euh ça a été euh comment dire
un un rejet des structures politiques
traditionnelles. C'est-à-dire que en
fait c'est un vote sanction avec une
mission très claire qui a été pour moi
de porter les revendication que j'avais
porté depuis 2018 parce que il faut
comprendre la situation aujourd'hui à
Mayotte comme le fruit du soulèvement de
2018. En 2018, Mayot s'est soulevé à
cause de l'insécurité provoquée par
l'immigration clandestine. La réponse
qui nous a été apportée n'était ni à la
hauteur du problème, ni en lien avec ce
que nous avions demandé. Nous avions
demandé de l'insécurité sur les de la
sécurité de la sécurité et la
mobilisation des forces de l'ordre et
une lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine. Sur les 5 années qui se
sont passées, on a juste eu un
déferlement de violence, pas de renfort.
Un ministre de l'intérieur Casttagère
qui va danser dans les bidonvillees avec
les clandestins. C'est-à-dire le prés le
le ministre Castaner est allé danser
quand même à la vigie au lieu de
l'immigration clandestine. Euh voilà.
Enfin, je veux dire pour nous ça a été
mais une humiliation. On a eu une série
de visites touristiques ministérielles.
À chaque fois pour aller vers le petit
bisou à son clandestin, on était
scandalisé.
Et donc sanction dans les ur et par
contre
je dois je dois retourner dans my je
dois retourner dans le myse
sur les élections locales que ce soit le
conseil départemental ou les municipales
où il y a énormément de participation
Mayotte reste principalement une une île
LR les Républicains. Et ça en fidélité
au président Sarkozy qui a accordé la
départementalisation
et c'est
une île sinon qui a beaucoup de
trajectoire personnelle mais qui est
très très mobilisé électoralement.
Question Wambouchou ça va pas les faire
bouger autre chose que ça va pas faire
bouger les bidonville un peu plus loin
dans dans la jungle ?
Mais ça c'était déjà le cas. C'est pour
ça que la question des reconduites, elle
est très importante. Si on ne si pendant
qu'on détruit les bidonville, on ne
procède pas au aux reconduite à la
frontière, évidemment on va juste
déplacer le problème et c'est
l'inquiétude de beaucoup de ma c'est
pour ça que que la que la question c'est
qu'il y ait une coordination qui soit
importante et un effort sur la durée.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe si on reconduit à
la frontière quelqu'un qui peut parouver
sa date de naissance et que en fin de
compte c'est un mineur qui était
scolarisé. Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Ça
existe ? Ça existe pas ? Il y a eu des
cas comme ça ou pas ?
Ah je sais pas. D'accord. La commission
des affaires étrangères
parce que il me reste que 10 minutes. Je
vais vous séquestrer hein. Je je vais
appeler la l'Assemblée nationale là.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait à la commission
affaires étrangères ? C'est les
vacances, c'est pas les vacances, c'est
pas [rires]
avec le président bourlange ? Non,
certainement pas. Qu'est-ce que vous
faites de là ?
La moi personnellement ou de de manière
générale
la Commission des affaires étrangères
comme la Commission des affaires
européenne est chargé non seulement
d'examiner
tous les traités, tous les accords
internationaux que passe la France, donc
qu'on valide, le travail en commission,
c'est un vote restreint qui sera après
qui va servir de vote pour l'Assemblée
nationale, sinon qui est le vote avant
celui qui aura dans l'hémicycle mais
tous les traités ne sont pas examinés
dans l'hémicycle. En gros, je la fais
courte. Donc ça c'est une grosse partie
de notre travail. Et puis il y a toutes
les missions qui sont euh des rapports
où en fait on s'empare de sujet et comme
je je j'ai évoqué avec vous par exemple,
on est de députés à travailler sur les
enjeux migratoires aux frontières sud de
l'Union européenne et de l'océan Indien.
Ça augmenté ou ça a pas augmenté
quoi ? les les flux de migrants dans la
Méditerranée sud.
Oui.
De combien ?
Euh moi je suis pas bonne avec les
chiffres mais ça a beaucoup augmenté là.
Là j'étais il y a de semaines enfin il y
a une semaine en Italie à Lampéoussa.
Les autorités italiennes font état d'une
augmentation
de plus de 200 %. Ils s'attendent à ce
qu'on ait au moins un demi million de
migrants qui arrivent par la
Méditerranée cette année et
principalement des francophones, des
migrants qui arrivent de Côte d'Ivoire
et de Guinée équatoriale. Ça veut dire
que c'est une migration qui ne va pas
rester en Italie et qui va venir en
France. Euh
et ça c'est sans prendre en compte la
l'instabilité qu'il y a au Soudan.
Et euh les Grecs par exemple nous ont
informé du fait queil y avait de plus en
plus de migrants qui arrivaient de
Palestine
euh et que donc eux ils constatent
qu'ils vont arriver des Libanais et des
Palestiniens, ce qu'ils ne voyaient pas
avant. Et donc moi ce que je peux
rapporter de la mission, c'est que les
flux migratoires reprennent.
Je peux gratter 15 minutes
bien sûr les 10. On négocie pas avec les
terroristes. [rires]
Les les 10 10 minutes les les flux
migratoires augmentent
euh change euh s'intensifie avec comme
ce qu'on peut voir à Mayotte, beaucoup
de mineurs qui sont en migration.
Et ça en fait nos systèmes d'asile et de
protection et d'immigration ne sont pas
du tout réfléchis pour une migration des
mineurs. C'est ce qu'on appelle les
mineurs étrangers isolés. euh pour la
France où on voit bien que euh pour pas
rentrer dans la cuisine politique, mais
en fait c'est important euh
la prise en charge des mineurs étrangers
isolés, elle est à la charge des
conseils départementaux.
C'est de la politique locale. Et en fait
le régalien, la protection de la
frontière, c'est l'État. Et nous, on
voit à Mayotte une tension entre notre
conseil départemental qui dit à l'État,
voilà la facture du fait que vous
protégez pas la frontière
parce que nous on est en train de payer
pour la santé infantile comme la
protection des mineurs isolés dans
l'aide sociale à l'enfance dont les
coûts ont explosé à Mayotte et qui sont
principalement absorbés par la
protection des mineurs comoriens.
Bah l'État,
notre conseil départemental est en
négociation avec l'État pour présenter
la facture et dire "Attendez, ça c'est
le fruit de votre incapacité à protéger
la frontière, donc vous allez régler la
facture."
Et ça euh c'est une discussion que moi
je je connais à Mayotte et qui est la
discussion qui a eu aussi en Grèce, qui
a eu aussi en Italie, qui ont eux
développé une politique nationale de
prise en charge des mineurs et qui voit
avec effar
mineurs seuls sur ces bateaux qui
déboulent et qui sont nous on le voit et
moi je l'ai dit à mes homologues en
Italie, petits enfants petits problèmes,
grands enfants grands problèmes. Nous,
on a à Mayotte des milliers de mineurs
qui ont grandi sans supervision adulte.
Une institution ne peut pas prendre en
charge un mineur, c'est faux. Un mineur
ne peut être prise en charge que par des
familles. Les familles d'accueil à
Mayotte, elles sont saturées. On est
au-delà des normes nationales. Et en
fait, s'il y a pas de supervision
d'adulte, un mineur dégénère. C'est
c'est se mentir que de refuser cette
réalité. C'est ce qui s'est passé après
le tremblement terre à Haïti avec les
les grands retardés. C'est ça.
Ouais, c'est c'est ça. Mais je pense je
pense qu'en fait si on ne réalise pas
qu'à Mayotte, les adultes sont en
minorité par rapport aux plus jeunes, on
ne comprend pas l'incapacité qu'on a
comme société à faire face au phénomènes
des mineurs isolés. C'est pour ça que
pour nous, c'est impératif qu'on
applique la circulaire Tobira et qu'il y
ait une prise en charge nationale de ces
mineurs avec une répartition de l'effort
parce que vous pouvez pas et je sais
bien que la prise en charge de l'enfance
en danger, l'enfant sans danger en
France, elle est elle est en grande
difficulté. Je dis pas le contraire,
mais à Mayotte, on est en train de
fabriquer des monstres. Et si on va
aller au bout de de de ce constat,
Non non non non non, on fabrique des
monstres parce que je vais vous dire,
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire une mauvaise
prise en charge des mineurs ? Ça veut
dire que ces enfants non seulement
deviennent dangereux pour eux-mêmes,
mais ils sont en danger parce qu'ils ne
sont pas protégés, parce qu'ils peuvent
être victimes d'abus sexuel, de travail
forcé, d'exploitation. C'est ça en fait.
cette cette défaillance des adultes,
cette défaillance du système envers les
plus faibles crée les problèmes de
demain et donc génère cette violence
après qu'il se retourne contre la
société.
Et comment pour arrêter des bateaux de
migrants mineurs ?
Ça c'est une question en fait qui est la
question d'aujourd'hui pour Mayotte mais
la question de demain pour tout le
continent européen. Parce qu'aujourd'hui
le droit
international, le droit de la mer, c'est
que n'importe quel bateau, quel que soit
son statut, on le secours.
Ce qui est une règle humaine.
À partir du moment où vous décidez,
comme l'ont fait l'OTAN et l'Union
européenne, qu'on peut instrumentaliser
des flux migratoires pour en faire une
menace hybride pour déstabiliser un
pays. Et c'est ce qu'on voit avec la
migration comorienne qui est
instrumentalisée par les autorités pour
déstabiliser Mayotte.
Est-ce que vous considérez que les
migrants qui sont en détresse sont une
menace et donc vous autorisez vos forces
de défense à réagir comme face à
n'importe quelle menace ?
On parle de gens dans des bateau c'est
pour ça que c'est une menace hybride.
C'est pour ça que c'est une menace
hybride et c'est pour ça que c'est un un
castette au niveau du droit.
Aujourd'hui, les autorités
en mer grec font ce qu'on appelle du
pushback. C'est-à-dire que quand elles
voit rentrer dans leurs eaux
territoriales des bateaux chargés de
migrants qui ne sont pas en détresse,
elle le repousse hors de leurs eaux.
Et ça c'est en train de créer un
précédent. Elle est repousse gentiment,
pas
elle repousse en créant des vagues. Elle
les repousse en en
limite en lesant chavirer.
Non, justement les zodiaques. Non,
en Non, ça ça les regarde moi. Ce n'est
pas ce que j'ai vu. C'est ce que
certaines associations rapportent. Mais
en fait euh moi je vais vous dire sur le
fond, j'ai du mal à y croire parce qu'en
fait si elle crevait le zodiaque, elle
serait forcée de faire le l'opération de
sauvetage, ce qui est pas du tout
l'objet de de la stratégie grecque. La
stratégie grecque c'est de pousser le
bateau hors de la zone des eaux grecs et
donc de la responsabilité des autorités.
Ça veut dire qu'en fait elles disent on
va appliquer la notion de frontière en
mer. Et ça aujourd'hui c'est pas clair.
C'est clair sur l'exploitation des
ressources. C'est clair sur
la pêche ou le le l'exploitation des
algues ou quoi que quoi quel que soit ce
que on peut observer à la avec la pêche
illégale, vous avez [rires] vous avez la
marque
vous avez la loi de programmation. Vous
avez vous avez la marine la marine qui
est autorisée à agir contre la pêche
illégale mais en fait on n' pas en terme
de droit de solution par rapport au
trafic humain illégal si ce n'est le
sauvetage. Et quand c'est le sauvetage
de fait on se retrouve en Grèce comme en
Italie comme à Mayotte où vous avez vos
forces d'ordre qui sont simplement en
train de transporter les migrants de la
mer à la terre. Et donc pour nous, pour
la population, on se dit "Mais en fait,
c'est pas de la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine, vous êtes en
train d'aider les migrants." Et donc ça
c'est ça c'est un sujet éminemment
politique qui n'est pas du ressort ni de
la défense ni des forces intérieures.
C'est pas la police, la gendarmerie, ni
nos marins, ni nos militaires qui vont
décider de notre politique d'asile et
immigration et de la réforme du droit en
mer. C'est nous parlementaires,
nous décideurs politiques qui devront
prendre ce débat. Et alors évidemment,
compte tenu du contexte politique
national et international, je vous peux
vous dire que ça va pas être une partie
de plaisir, que ça va pas être d'une
grande finesse. Je ne suis pas sûre que
ce soit à la hauteur des enjeux très
honnêtement parce que
les projections de l'ONU sur des
millions de personnes qui vont prendre
les routes de l'exil sur les prochaines
décennies pour fuir les catastrophes, la
famine ou le changement climatique
ou la guerre
ou la guerre, ben évidemment que ça va
nous interroger nous pays d'accueil et
est-ce que en suivant les mots de
recard, on peut pas accueillir toute la
misère du monde, Ben si le cas, comment
est-ce qu'on trie ? Comment est-ce qu'on
accueille ? Comment est-ce qu'on refoule
? C'est des questions que je formule
très simplement mais qui en fait
philosophiquement nous interrogent et
induisent une fois qu'on aurait répondu
à cette question toute une mise en œuvre
d'une politique qui soit cohérente.
Actuellement aujourd'hui, on est dans
une politique nationale avec beaucoup
d'angles morts et on est dans une
politique européenne complètement
contradictoire et chaotique.
C'est-à-dire que certains pays du nord
de l'Europe décident queen fait ils
allongent financièrement au niveau des
pays frontaliers avec l'Afrique en
disant "On fait notre part, on paye."
Et vous avez des pays du sud qui par les
urnes disent on peut plus et en fait on
va changer, on va réduire les règles
d'accueil de l'asile,
on va réduire les droits des étrangers
et il y a une réponse de rejet politique
organisé. Et moi ce que j'ai pu observer
c'est qu'il y a quand même une remise en
question fondamentale du droit d'asile
dans ces pays du sud. Le droit d'asile
en Europe, il est hérité de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale. Le droit d'asile, ça
veut dire protection pour celles et ceux
qui sont en danger. Comme il y a eu abus
du droit d'asile, aujourd'hui, ce droit
même est en danger. Et ça, je pense que
c'est pour ça que j'ai abordé tout à
l'heure la question de est-ce qu'on
octroit le statut de réfugiés à celles
et ceux qui fuient leur pays à cause du
changement climatique, c'est parce que
ça induit beaucoup de droits pour
comment dire les les personnes et
d'obligation pour les pays d'accueil.
Mais vous voyez, je vais je vais
terminer là-dessus. [grognement] J'ai eu
une discussion avec une amie. J'ai une
amie, non mais j'ai une amie qui me
disait qu'elle vivait en Asie et elle me
dit "Les pays asiatiques, la Chine, le
Japon, la Corée n'accueille pas de
migrants." Point.
Et elle me dit "Nous en Europe, on est
convaincu et on a cette mission et on
accueille. On accueille mal peut-être,
mais on accueille."
Elle dit la discussion sur l'immigration
ne peut être qu'une discussion mondiale
comme pour le changement climatique. Et
donc il faudra à un moment que les pays
occidentaux forcent les pays euh
asiatiques à prendre leur part de
migrant et il ne s'agira pas il ne
s'agira pas de simplement payer.
Question internet. L'Union des Comors
est membre de la Ligue arabe et de
l'organisation de la coopération
islamique. A-t-elle sollicité la
solidarité de ces organisations ?
question dez
solidarité financière. Oui, absolument.
La ligue arabe, la ligue islamique paye
beaucoup d'argent au com
c'est c'est c'est leur problème. Il y a
une influence islamique
à Mayot ou pas de de d'imames qui sont
parachutés sur place ou pas du tout ?
Comment ça se passe ?
Non, Mayotte est une terre musulmane
traditionnellement. Euh par contre ce
qu'on observe c'est que les pratiques
comme les comors sont traversées par euh
euh des influenos français chrétien non
c'est pas ça. C'est que les les comors
sont traversées par des radicalités
chiites sunnites et que par les migrants
qui viennent et qui installent des
mosquées clandestines à Mayotte, elles
apportent leurs propres pratiques qui
sont contrairement contraires à ce elles
sont totalement contraires à nos
traditions à nous. Et donc nous, on
observe une concurrence par rapport à
nos pratiques traditionnelles et un
questionnement, une remise en question.
Évidemment, on peut pas se dire que
quand vous êtes avec des bidonvillees
euh des personnes qui sont tout à fait
mur pour être radicalisé que ça ne pose
pas un risque pour la sécurité publique.
C'est pour ça que le ministre de
l'intérieur avait dit lors des des
justificatifs pour l'opération en
bouchou qu'il y avait la question du
terrorisme pour Mayotte. Il y a un
risque.
J'ai 21h55. Je dois y aller.
Donc dernière question qui n'est pas une
question, c'est conseiller tris livres
20h55 j'espère. Pas 21h55.
20h55
sinon
c'est la dernière fois que vous faites
ça. C'est pas 1h45 [rires] je vais me
fâcher. [grognement]
Trois bouquins à revenir
il y a intérêt euh trois trois trois
livres à conseiller à notre communauté.
Des livres qui ont été importants pour
vous et un conseil pour les jeunes
générations. Et après je vous laisse
filer pour aller parler de la loi de
programmation militaire. Trois livres
qui ont été importants pour moi. Les
fleurs du mal de Baudler.
Euh
un deuxième livre,
[grognement] le prince de Maiavel
et Saint-Germain ou la négociation qui
est un livre qui
m'a permis de
de comprendre la subtilité. C'est-à-dire
que moi, j'étais quelqu'un de très
euh euh
linéaire et en fait pour moi la
littérature, elle m'a appris à
comprendre le double discours et un
monde qui est multidimensionnel. Moi,
j'avais toujours en fait ma réflexion,
elle est plate, elle est assez simple et
en fait la littérature m'a permis de de
comprendre qu'il pouvait y avoir euh euh
de la complexité,
euh du sous-entendu,
euh
du double discours, enfin de sortir du
simplisme dans lequel j'étais.
Vous êtes mur pour pour devenir
diplomate ?
Non. un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Je serai jamais diplomate. Ça ça je
pense que peut-être que dans les propos
qui ont été tenus un peu plus tôt où on
disait que que je chauffais à blanc les
gens, je suis très intolérante et très
radicale dans mon engagement pour
Mayotte. Mais parce que je pense que
notre île a besoin de radicalité parce
que les problèmes sont radicalement
graves. Donc non, je pense pas que j'ai
une once de diplomatie et personne ne
peut le penser. [rires]
Ça c'est clair.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations,
une bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
d'impérissable.
Engagez-vous, battez-vous, aimez, aimez
fort.
J'en profite, j'embrasse Mayotte et et
mes potes Mauré Comorien et et je passe
je passerai d'autres Bonjour plus tard.
Estelle Youssoufa, merci beaucoup.
Merci à vous. C'est c'est un petit
plaisir d'avoir cette discussion.
Attends, on vous attend pour un deuxième
épisode parce que 1h45 c'est trop court
surtout sur ce type de sujet là. OK,
avec plaisir.
Etoufa. Merci.
Merci à vous.
[musique]